If I send you my labs, do you look at them and decide if we need to talk about them?
I want you to send me your labs, send us your labs so that we can get them in your folder.
But no, I'm not going to, I just don't have time to look at everybody's labs and then decide
if we need to talk to them. That takes anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes to really look at everybody's
lab. Sometimes it could take longer than if I could period to pass labs. You're going to have
to make that decision because if I did it order those labs specifically, then you know, you're
getting those labs down and you're going to have to make that decision whether you want to speak
with me. So, on the rare occasion that I have time and I do look at some of these labs, there's
probably somebody listed in this and well, you called and said you wanted to talk to me after that.
After you looked at my lab, there's times that I do have time and I look at them.
But usually, I don't. So, it just gets put in your file.
So, it is ultimately your responsibility to, hey, I need to talk to them about my labs.
So, otherwise, it's just, I don't have enough time in the day to do that. Sorry.